It's,uh, late March - several years ago - and I'm in the Jacksonville Memorial...
Jacksonville Memorial Gardens graveyard and, uh,
And, uh, I've got on this black suit and I'm lost.
And this black suit I wear here. Every. Every time I come here this time of year
year and By the end of the day the suit will.
Suit will have grass stains on my knees. I'll have walked
walked this area several times looking for a grave that I can't find. And, um, I
And I will feel like...
like, the worst human being in the world. The worst
The worst ex-husband. The worst father
Because I can't find the grave of my daughter.
Lauren Lashonda Letson was born March 27, 1999. She also
passed away on that day. But how we got there is a long story
long story. It goes back way back. See, I got married really young- I mean really young
mean really young, so young that I was actually playing with Legos and reading comic books at the time
time and. You know, the marriage might have worked out. It may have
been OK, but, right after we got married I got a call from the Seattle Tacoma
Seattle-Tacoma, Washington District Attorney's office telling me that I had a paternity case against me.
case against me.
me. See when I was seventeen I'd gotten a girl pregnant I didn't know about it. She moved away and six years later
years later she popped up. And
up and. So that really put a lot of strain on a young relationship
young relationship. Um, and so, at the time, I was a flight attendant, which
flight attendant, which was really cool because when things got bad at home, I could get on the plane and leave, but
leave, but you know as time went on, um, and you have a couple
a couple that has the emotional maturity of the entire cast of 90210 [laughter]
The first series, not the second. [laughter]
Things get
get really hard, you know, and it just became a little bit impossible and
Impossible and things were falling apart everywhere, and as we all
As we all know when a marriage is falling apart, the number one thing you need to do to
to bring that marriage
bring that marriage together, is have a baby. And so I
so I wasn't really excited
really excited about having a child, I mean you know I was just kind of like, you know
like like, you know whatever. It's whatever. I would go to all the doctor visits. I did all the
all the requisite things that, you know, a good husband a father does, but I wasn't crazy
about the idea
idea. And then one night, um, I was in the bed with my ex-wife and
ex-wife and, um, my back was to her stomache
stomach. And the baby started kicking me. And she kicked
kicked so hard- it was really late at night, like one o'clock. She kicked so hard that it woke me
up and, you know, I'm a little groggy
groggy and so I poked her back. [laughter] And she kicked! And I poked
I poked and she kicked and I poked and she kicked and, and we must have played for about a
half an hour. You know, it was a great time until her mother woke up and told us both to go to
sleep. [laughter] So, um, after that
that you know, I, I fell in
I, I fell in love. I would play music on her stomach, I would sing to her, I would read books to her,
books to her- the whole nine. I, I fell in love with this little girl. And when my wife gave
wife gave birth to, uh, my daughter, Brooklyn, she
she came out and she was screaming. And I walked over to her and I said, "What's the matter baby?"
baby?" and she stopped screaming and she turned her head towards me, and after that, like, the deal was sealed.
was sealed. Like,
Like, I, you know, she was, uh, she would cry sometimes, you know, as an infant.
And all I had to do was come in the room and she'd stop. I used to have conferences with her when she was like six months old, telling her
old telling her, "You know, listen. You have to be nicer to your mother. It's not cool that you only want me." She was
She she was really tight with me, but
me. But, the marriage didn't get better. Things were falling apart, and I wasn't the
best husband, I was really immature. And, after a while I decided that, I just,
I had to leave.
So, we, we, started doing the, uh, break up game, where you go away for a week and then you come
back and you go away for a week and you come
back and, one of those weeks when I had come back, one thing led to another and,
She got pregnant again. And, I, I thought to myself, "Well, OK. OK. I can't
I, I can't leave now. Like, you know, what kind of man would I be to leave this woman with
this woman with two
with two little babies?" So, I decided to stick it out but I was
just so angry. You know? Because I felt
like my entire life I didn't know who I was and I was finally beginning to figure that out.
And who I was, wasn't really fitting into this concept of what
this marriage was. But, I decided to stay and, you know, I did all the
things that a good father is supposed to do.
I went to all the doctor's appointments. You know, I tolerated the baby shower
all of that stuff.
You know, and, um, one night, I was laying in the bed and, her
stomach was pressed up against my back, and the baby kicked.
and this time
I was so angry. And so ticked off
that I got up and got out the bed
And slept somewhere else. And every time when the baby would kick, and I would feel it I would
get up and move. And I didn't play any songs for her, didn't talk to her, didn't
do anything. You know I
just pulled myself away from her. So one morning I
wake up and, um, and her mother says there's something's wrong.
And later she would tell me that, uh, when she woke up, she didn't
feel pregnant anymore. And it's... It's funny like when you go to the hospital under
these circumstances... It's quiet. Nobody really
talks to you. No one wants to say anything.
The nurses kind of keep their eyes on the ground and, um, they finally
come over and they tell us that they couldn't find a heartbeat and, my daughter Lauren was gone.
She was, uh, nine months pregnant. About a week away from delivering
the baby.
And to me it just seems so crazy, like, I understood like, you know, a miscarriage happening earlier
in the pregnancy but like, at nine months you, you think that, like, nothing's going to go wrong at this point.
So, at nine months pregnant, you have to give birth. And it's
just like, you know, regular labor, and I remember everything about it. I remember the room. I
remember the way it smelled. I remember, the weight of Lauren,
after she was born and they gave me to her [her to me?]
exactly how she felt in my arms.
And I remember being surprised at how warm her body was, you know, I thought because she had passed
away that, her body would be cold, but, it was really warm. And when I looked down at her
she was the spitting image.
Of my daughter Brooklyn. It could have been her twin. At this point Brooklyn
is about a year old
a year old or so and I'm, uh
I'm, uh, I'm looking at this baby in my arms.
And for the first time you know I want her, more than anything in this world.
And there's a nurse behind me,
And, I, I, I...
I think to myself if I don't hand her to the nurse now,
I won't ever be able to let her go. So I give her to the nurse and
she walks away and, um,
God, I just remember everything: my mom was in the room and, she had brought Brooklyn to
the hospital to see us and, Brooklyn actually took her first steps in that
hospital room, she crawled, walked, stumbled over to
me and, um, Couple days later
Couple days later we do the funeral at the Jacksonville memorial and, I'm in that
black suit. And I remember my family being there and,
I remember my mother giving me all the cards.
For bereavement. I put one of them in my suit pocket and they must of came off of some
flowers because there was a pin, and the pin pricked me. And it really hurt, and right when that pin pricked
me my mother said to hold on to these cards, because you needed the write 'Thank You' cards
to everybody. And I thought, "I'm not writing anybody any fucking 'Thank You' cards."
And I'm there and they bury my daughter, and
And we go home and, you know I
stay with her mother
About as long as I could, is what I felt was a proper amount of time before I could actually
leave. Because, I just, I couldn't take it anymore I,
I couldn't stand
to look at her. Not because I thought that she had done something wrong, but because I felt that
I had done something wrong. Like I couldn't
stand her even looking my way because I just felt so
guilty that my little
girl, As she's grown up, you know, she
was fascinated with the idea that she has a little sister that passed
away and she would ask me about it all the time and, and I would tell her anything she wanted to know except when
she asked me
me how she died. I just could never bring that up, I could give her
the physical explanation of, you know, the umbillical cord got wrapped around her legs and cut
off circulation and she passed away. I could give her that, but I felt in my heart that that was
a lie.
That she died because, because she thought her daddy didn't love
her. And it ate me up.
And I couldn't tell my little girl that. So I would always tell it just to ask somebody
else, ask her mother. Years later, I meet somebody,
Fall in love
love. And, you know, there are just some things that don't ever get better.
You know and the person that I meet she tells me that I'm great. I tell her that I'm a murderer she
tells me, "No you're not." And, and you know,  it feels good for someone to
say it, even though I didn't believe it.
And we get married. She gets pregnant.
And I'm overjoyed, I'm so happy. You know, And I am there
There, You know more than I've ever been, like, I'm there at the doctors things, I was actually happy at the
baby shower. But the [mumbled "it was a task"] [laughter]
But, you know, I have
this fear in me that's
just eating me whole. So much so that, like, the whole front of my head
goes gray. I actually dye my hair now. But the whole front of my hair goes gray and while
all my other friends when, when their wives get pregnant they gain weight with their wives, I start
to lose weight, and I can't sleep at night and, anything my wife tells me is wrong, I'm obsessing
about it. I'm staying up all night long. I'm just a wreck. You know, the slightest
little think could tick me off and,
She's about, eight or nine months pregnant, and my daughter Brooklyn, who I'm still
extremely tight with, She asked me if this was the same
time that Lauren passed away. And I
tell her yes. And she asked me, "How did Lauren die?"
And I just fell apart.
I just wept and wept. I mean, I couldn't stop
crying. And my little girl, she comes over to
me and, she wraps her arms around me and she
says, "Daddy, I used to dream about Lauren.
And she told me to tell you that it's
OK". After my, uh,
Son was born - healthy and beautiful -
The next March, I went back
to Jacksonville Memorial Gardens, and instead of
like, wandering, looking for a grave that I can't find I actually
went inside, and I asked him, you know,
"Why can't I find my daughter? Help me." And they told me
that when Lauren was buried, we didn't have a lot of money, we could
barely afford the plot and we never paid for a permanent
permanent stone. That we just had a temporary marker
that had been pulled up
up. And, so I, I um, I paid them.
To put a marker down, for my daughter, but I've never even seen it. See, I,
I didn't have to go back there anymore. Because Lauren told
me that it was OK
OK.